good evening Mars from the surface man's
age-old dream of a close-up look at what
it's like on another planet and of
searching for life there today became a
reality and what a reality it's been
more than 40 years since the Viking one
landed on Mars and sent back the first
images from the Red Planet
since then nASA has successfully
operated six other unmanned landing
craft and vehicles on the Martian
surface this week the Space Agency
debuted its next-generation Mars rover
set to be launched in 2020 but now we're
getting a look at what a future manned
Mars rover might look like
Omar Villafranca took it for a spin at
the Kennedy Space Center with six wheels
and a distinctive alien design tourists
at the Kennedy Space Center Visitor
Complex have no idea what to make of
this extraterrestrial machine this is a
new Mars rover concept vehicle standing
11 feet tall
24 feet long and 13 feet wide what takes
longer your design or you putting it
together the giant Rover is the
brainchild of the Parker Brothers
Shannon and mark
the two made their names in Hollywood
designing and building movie props most
notably the futuristic motorcycles in
the movie Tron
no doors on Mars you have to get into
through the back right Shannon designed
the rover mark and his team did the
dirty work constructing the whole thing
in less than five months there is almost
nothing on this vehicle that was not
built in our shop I mean down to every
little bracket and Tabish nothing was
ordered out of a catalog we built the
body the chassis the suspension the
wheels the frame the interior the seats
the glass everything on this vehicle had
to be built completely from scratch some
of this was just for a design you know
just for it to look cool other things I
thought you know this is kind of
important to have I'm being very
delicate with it this is the speed you
would end up doing on Mars you're not
true on the inside of the rover seats
four and drives like an SUV but there's
also a mock lab in the back where
astronauts could conceivably conduct
experiments some of the features were
designed with exploration in mind so we
needed a good surface area for the rock
to climb over but then we needed a lot
of surface area so when you get into the
sand it's not going to sink but it also
has these vents in it so it's not going
to clog up so it can go through really
deep sand not get stuck and not get
clogged up all the same time the brother
is consulted with astronauts when
building the machine but this vehicle
won't go to Mars instead it's on an
earthbound mission to educate future
scientists about the Red Planet you
really believe that doesn't really do
believe that US astronaut John McBride
flew to Space Shuttle missions and says
putting the first person on Mars is
closer than we think we think that the
first man or woman on Mars is somewhere
between eight 18 years old as we speak
right now so these guys are in the third
fourth fifth grade up through somewhere
in college or after the folks at the KSC
Visitor Complex hope the attraction will
generate enthusiasm like in 2012 when
the unmanned Curiosity rover landed on
Mars
is public enthusiasm about it does that
have any bearing on what is decided in
Washington I think it has a lot of
bearing I was congressional director for
NASA and people say well you ought to
write your Congressman but very few
people do that the eye-grabbing rover
goes on display at the Kennedy Space
Center's journey to Mars exhibit
starting June 5th
Omar Villafranca CBS this morning
Saturday at the Kennedy Space Center in
Central Florida ok I want to do it I
want to drive that literally if you
build it they will go yeah yeah I want
to drive it I want drive it on Mars to
those wheels
I wasn't wheeled on my bike we adapt
them I don't know